I went to the DMV with Willie Nelson one
time we both had to take our driving
test together or like the you know the
written part so maybe studying with
Willie helped me to pass this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when driving in fog you should use your
a high beams below beams
see fog lights only fog lights only says
fog in it but which is driving at night
don't drive on fog lights on me or your
high beams you Michael no low beams boom
drop the pencil I'm gonna go with low
beams high beams are reflective in the
fog low beams yeah when do you use the
fog light when driving in fog don't use
your fog lights whatever you do which of
the following is the most effective in
avoiding a collision the answer is don't
drive a keeping your lights on at all
times be wearing a seatbelt see keeping
a cushion of space at all time by
keeping a cushion of space Oh see
keeping your efficient of space at all
times what's a cushion of space do I
sleep on a fish in this space different
what my bed is gonna keep me from
colliding with people I don't know well
it white painted curve means seriously a
loading zone for Freight or passengers
be loading zones for passengers or mail
only see loading zone for free only a
loading zone for freight and passengers
dammit I live in New York we don't drive
ok first of all that's that's not true
because the post office person in my
neighborhood and never parks on the
white curb they always find my car and
block it
how many drinks does it take to impair
your driving can I just get this right
cuz I don't drink more than three drinks
it depends on the person's height and
weight one drink I'm sure it's wondering
crying what one drink you're right you
should never drive if you've had a drink
what is an ozone a a no parking zone be
a no stopping or a loading zone see none
of the above I'm saying gonna be above
unless it to me trying to avoid eating
cake that's a no zone
okay I'm gonna go none of the above
because there's a none of the above you
always choose none of the above if there
is one right how many feet must you stop
before a crosswalk oh man a five feet be
10 feet 15 feet oh my god these people
are dead in my world I don't know I mean
as long as you stop by at the crosswalk
is that normal pretty good I'm gonna
save 5 feet 5 feet
right 5 feet 5 feet is nothing people
want me to hurt some people before
changing lanes on a freeway you should
signal for at least a 5 seconds be 10
seconds see 15 seconds that I think
depends on your age because if you're
110 I think you just always drive with
the signal on right 5 seconds
emoji of a nail and emoji of a hammer
nailed it so I just failed I'm scared to
be on the road with me I will never get
my driver's license I'm gonna go get my
car now and drive anyway sort of care so
forget you guys the thing with the fog
the fog we would be driving in fog or
whatever all right what do you do when
you drive in fog
I don't know pull over listen to music
until it's gone like blues driving in
fog what am i fat man like I don't know